Hello, hello, hello, hello,
welcome to Shashingo!
What's the pun?
On Shashin?
And Nihongo.
Shashingo.
Or if it's Shashingo, wouldn't it be like photography
language?
Teach us Nihongo.
Kyowa.
Kyowa, Nihongo.
In this game, you take pictures and you learn Japanese.
Let's all be weeps together.
Wow.
Meat, you're Japanese, good.
Oh, he's saying that kind of nice.
Oh, thank you very much.
That's such a good thank you, isn't it?
Wow, it's super good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Uh, yeah, yeah, still, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What?
Oh, what?
My Nihonko is very sugoi.
I believe you!
I believe you.
Actually, yesterday...
Was it yesterday?
Yes.
Yesterday, Matara and I, we both bought our...
Our... Oh, sorry.
Something fell on my desk.
Our tickets to Japan!
So before...
Kanji mo yommerun da.
Sugoi.
Kanji...
Kanji yommerasen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, let me know.
Nihonko!
Yeah, we bought our tickets to Japan, so now it feels so
much more real.
But...
Oh, my gosh, this music's going to put me to sleep.
Um...
Uh...
Uh, what was I going to say?
It was so funny.
When we were buying them, we were buying them together.
and i bought mine i ended up like like i ended up putting in
all my information first and buying my ticket first and then
she goes to buy hers and we got ours separately but um we
put our seats next to each other and um and uh when she went
to go buy hers it said that it was sold out So I was like,
oh, I didn't take it.
I didn't take it.
But in the end, it worked out.
It was too slow.
I took her seat.
Oh, no.
Japan, it's hot.
Oh, man.
This is hot.
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
I like the lo-fi of this.
I really wanted, like, a kind of chill game.
And, uh, um, something that, uh, uh, Riguma, Shiterno?
Riguma!
Um, uh, what's his name?
Oh, no.
Um, oh, Steve Jobs!
Who
is Steve Jobs?
Miigmaq is an English meme.
It's an English meme.
Don't worry about it.
Who is Steve Jobs?
Who?
Steve Jobs.
But yeah, yesterday I talked so much.
I wanted something today that is a little less, like, a
little less talk-intensive and a little more chill and a
little more.
Just going around and learning some Nihon Go.
And we can study...
Kimi No Nihon Go Honto Ni Jozu.
Thank you.
Hi, Minto.
Today is actually my birthday, so I can ask her a happy
birthday from Portia Ridge.
Oh my gosh, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Oh, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, David, Ty, Taney, and Pee-Pee.
Happy birthday.
Oh, to you, you little peasant.
Thank you, gozhu.
Thank you.
Hi, Mint.
Hello.
Hi, little boy.
Posh voice, jozhu.
Everything is jozhu.
And not everything can be jozhu.
Not everything can be jozhu.
Let's do it again.
Japan has over 5 mil...
Oh.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
It's raining!
Welcome to Shashingo!
Here you'll use your camera to create unique photo
flashcards for learning Japanese.
You're free to explore your surroundings and study at your
own pace without any pressure.
Oh!
In-world translations!
Besides learning new vocabulary with your camera, you also
come across Japanese texts in various places while
exploring.
Interacting with the text will allow you to view the
original Japanese text along with the translation.
Oh my gosh!
I can't hear you over the sounds of Japan.
5 million, what?
5 million!
I'll give you this joke one more try before retiring it.
I apologize.
What?
Oh my gosh, it's so quiet because...
Hold on.
I'm gonna get through.
Let me get through this real quick and then I'll turn the
sound down.
Open your camera when you're ready.
Learn how to use it.
Okay, hold on.
Oh!
Maid, Maid Dreamin!
I'm sorry, Maid Melody.
Okay, audio.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my God.
Peace.
This is, like, going to real Japan.
This is, like, real.
This is, like, going to real.
Wow, the first thing we see is a Maid Campari!
Oh, my gosh!
Maid, main melody, main melody.
Oh my gosh!
Ah!
Very good.
Where are we?
I wonder.
Hmm.
I wonder where we are.
Oh wait, how do I...
Oh, right click is uh...
What?
Rainbow team.
Hey, that's not Japanese.
That's not Nihon-go.
Let's see.
What do we...
Let's take a picture of the maids.
Oh, operating the camera.
Operating the camera is easy and there are only a few
buttons to remember.
To take a photo, simply frame your subject by adjusting your
position and go and zoom.
Then press the shutter button when you're ready.
Oh, there's filters.
Oh my gosh.
You'll get kicked out if you take a picture of them.
You're so right.
Don't take pictures of the maids, you guys.
While it's not mandatory, holding the shutter button allows
you to lock up.
Lock on.
I'm locking.
You can adjust the composition even more freely.
Release the shutter button.
Oh, releasing the shutter button will then take the picture.
Framing the subject correctly.
Oh, look at that.
You can make it look so much better.
Your subject needs to fill a good portion of the frame to be
recognized by the camera.
gift and thank you as long as the viewfinder says displays
or japanese word you can freely take a photo okay okay well
this one let's see what what is made melody uh kasha kambang
kambang oh my gosh they're not made at all they're a
signboard oh my gosh i recognize all of this from iraustoya
Kanban!
Nice photo.
You just made your first photo flashcard.
As you can see, the subject of the photo is written on it in
Japanese.
Along with the translation.
Flipping it will also reveal an additional related
vocabulary.
And then we can add borders.
And save and discard.
Okay, let's see.
Oh!
Wait, how do I see the back?
Oh, right click.
Yomu to read.
Oki large.
Not my.
I don't know what these have to do with this, but, um, nice.
I don't know what they have to do with the Kanban, but...
Kanban!
We have a photo album.
We can get star stickers.
As you master words, they'll also receive star stickers.
Marking your favorite.
In-game lessons.
Wow.
Oh.
Whoa, it's nighttime!
Uh-oh, I hope no creepers come out.
Let's see this one.
Let's see this one What do you guys think this is?
Don't say Sakurai Station The moon's out.
Oh wait, how do I get out of camera mode?
Oh, you're right
Zoom Lock on
What's the...
YOLU?
Night.
KURAI.
Samui.
Cold weather.
You don't eat something and say it's Samui.
It's a...
Karaoke.
Wait, why is it question mark here?
Oh.
It's...
whole karaoke?
Karaoke.
Utau.
Warau.
Ureshi.
Got to see my bus friend, got offered a new job, and been
streaming all my birthday!
Cooper!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Cooper White Happy birthday to a you Happy birthday.
Oh testing your memory find modes find mode puts your memory
to the test to reinforce your vocabulary knowledge You'll be
given one of the Japanese words from your photo flashcards
and tasked with photographer to photography and photo
Photographing Photographing it in the game world.
Cool.
Word mastery.
And we can get new...
Oh my gosh, there's gotcha too.
Oh, heck, yeah.
Students are 10% off.
What's this?
Corkococococ!
Advertisement.
Koukoku Posta Chigai Mas Senden Suru To advertise You call
Effective Mirokuteki Appealing, oh my gosh When you see When
you see a mint channel You're like, oh Wow Mirokuteki na
channel Oh, I should go look right now now.
Oh, I can't do these, though.
Thank you.
Oh, wait, Joshua, I missed yours too.
I'm so sorry.
Good day to you, Mint.
I hope you are having a wonderful day.
Wonderful Minty day.
Thank you.
Have you ever watched any films in the Gaio genre?
I don't know if I have.
I hope I said it right.
Shashinto, kawaii, obaki, maido.
Wait, wait.
Maido?
Wait, oh, is it maido?
How is my broken Japanese sensei?
It's good.
Don't worry about it.
Let's take this picture.
Oh, which one do we?
Do I hear someone singing in here?
Hold on.
There's voice lines?
I think I hear a ghost in here.
You hear it?
What are they singing?
It was a lady singing before she was like, Shashin Ghost.
That's why my...
It was my art tag, but my general tag is Shinbei Shashin,
which means like spirit photography.
Interesting.
Oh my god, sorry, I'm so sorry.
Konichiwa!
Konichiwa.
Wait, what did you say?
Do you watch anime desuaka?
Not sugoi desu.
Watashiwa I'm learning Japanese.
Through all the anime, Watashi watches desu.
Watashi love talking about animas.
X3, Nuzzles, Ulu.
Have a konbama.
Hey,
have a konbama.
Everybody?
Wow, we stayed up all night in front of this karaoke place.
Is this...
Is this Shizen?
Oh, gosh.
My kanji.
Miraiyo.
Is that...
I don't know.
No, mecha only.
So yeah, returning to nature.
Try taking a photo.
I was trying to do it myself.
Let's see.
Lega Costa.
No, what does it say?
Me do.
To watch.
Engidu.
To perform.
Kando teki.
Moving.
It was my birthday yesterday.
I had a fun, low quality, high latency Discord karaoke
session with my friends and watch Dune 2.
Is that the one with the...
Is that the one?
Oh, she didn't.
Is that the one with the popcorn?
The chonki.
Also, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday to John Keirieria Happy birthday to you!
Wait, do I just click it?
My life is just one mech only one mech can save the future
Mirai Sekai Future Oh, I didn't even see the three Future
World 3 Shizen Nimo Doru Return to Nature Happy Eager
Rainbow Team Rescue Oh, oh, I It does say Rescue Mission I
was like Just says Rainbow Team rainbow team.
Commander Kinta?
Kinda?
Oh, Kane- Fuck.
Kane da- Oh, shit.
This is just gonna make me look so stupid.
I'm really bad with Kanji, you guys.
Kane da-kun.
Oh, Kanji, how do you do you?
Oh, Nomi-kun-yomi,
Under a pink sky.
This is the Iriiguchi.
Your entrance.
Oh, I can't read the...
Okay.
I can read the Ega Khan.
Is it Daku?
Something...
entertainment cinema oh go like go like go like go like go
go like go like go like go whoa oh my gosh guitar star
she's got a smile that seems to me of childhood memories
where everything was as fresh as the bright blue sky
guitar star wow i feel like this is actually so helpful
because it like actually kind of shows you things like that
you would really see and like in a context that you would
see it.
Hanabi Taikai!
Wait, can you read that?
Maybe you have to zoom in.
That's the skin.
No!
Sora.
Akaureen.
Aze.
A Kumori.
Beautiful.
Wait, so if I take a picture of...
Oh, whoa, this is big.
Is it just auega-can?
Auega-can.
Auega-can, everybody.
Miru.
D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-Date-D-D-Date-D..
Good thing you'll never need to know that.
I wonder how big this map is
Okay, so I'm like I know what it said Okay, it lasts 48
hours Right?
Natural Natural scent But natural scent that lasts I can't
read it though That's the thing about like kanji that I do
like Sometimes it's just like this is This is like the kanji
for Suzuki you know And like the kanji for um but sorry my
brain but i can't read them together but then i'm just like
but i know what they are separately so it like it like
already it like already means or i can already kind of make
an educated guess you know i've already dated all your
oshiminto who who have you dated who tell me right now tell
me the date tell me the time tell me Everything that you
did.
Tell me their natural scent.
Tell me what they wore.
Tell me how they did their hair.
Tell me the color of their eyes.
Tell me what they said, the first thing that they said when
they saw you.
Tell me everything.
That's what I saw.
That's what I thought.
Have it on her desk by Monday.
Look at her with her natural calorie.
I have no money.
It's all the filters, though.
Okay, I should be taking more photos.
That's the point of the game, right?
Oh, what's this?
Wait.
It lit up.
Oh, wait.
It's Koraku again.
Wait, but what else lit up then?
I saw it.
We saw it, right?
Oh.
Oh, it was just reminding me.
It was like, um, dummy, you already...
You already took a picture of this one.
Idiot.
God.
What about this?
What do you think this is called, everybody?
gamer laptop gamer gamer laptop note i'm happy you're
streaming on my birthday why is it everybody's birthday
today this game is a surprisingly good way to learn kana for
beginners oh nice crazy parza and happy birthday happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you Dear crazy person
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday How much you want to
bet one of the synonyms or like the related words is takai
What a scowl to use Let's get it to turn on Download to
download Gosh, you have to pay You have to pay so much more
Just to get the RGB What do you think?
Oh, my favorite show Oh, no, I missed it I missed it Oh, my
gosh, she's so loud MIR Tskeru Kessu Is that mine?
just a phone in this box.
It's not my birthday.
It's not your birthday as well?
Well, here's some money for non-birthday haver minty ghost.
This is a cute game.
Thank you for the non-birthday money.
What about the phone?
Smartphone.
Smartphone!
Cakeru.
Jiu-Den-Suru.
That's an important one, isn't it?
Very good.
Sumajo.
What you call me?
Yeah, I called you a...
Oh, make 10 photo flashcards.
Oh.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, cute.
Oh, this one's mysterious.
Okay, hold on.
Desoako.
I always...
Not always, but...
Sometimes I confuse this word, rei zoko, with the word for
candle.
Sometimes I'll instead say candle, which is, I can't
remember right now.
Yes, rÅsoku.
Yes, sometimes I confuse the rei zoko.
But I always think of the rei.
part because it's like the cold, you know?
Why candle?
It's similar to me.
Oh, wow.
This is nice camera.
I'm gonna turn down the lady's voice.
It's so loud.
Denshi-denshi-denshi-denshi-denshi-denshi-denshi-denshi-denshi-denshi.
Oh, maybe the voice lines.
That's what we're...
There we go.
Apply.
Denshi-denshi-denshi hype.
What's this thing?
Okay, you put it in the game.
It's important enough.
cabinet what's in here a power box I have no idea it's
important enough to be in the game just a box oh what about
this thing oh my gosh cute it even has like the kanji for
like learning manhole manhole what are the what are the
metal do you guys know that bird that like they'll be like
hey what's this made of and he goes metal or rock or he goes
shrek because of that bird i can't not say it as metal
apollo yes yes yes anna marui round anna hola is that a
do it do it oh they're so respectful actually sorry is this
um baby days could I please know what that is baby days do
you want to get you set guide maybe Atelier!
Elis.
Okonomiaki.
Nice.
Oh, I keep forgetting that we've got this one.
But I kind of want to keep the baby days.
Let's keep the baby days.
Oh my gosh, you could really take a picture of so many
things in this game.
Sankaku Kone!
It's a triangle code!
Sankaku code!
No way!
The Sankaku code!
It's just...
Watching your stream at work makes my day is so much better!
So have the tip some dude just gave you No!
Keep your own tip you deserve that.
Ton gata Pointy.
Koji.
Construction.
Oku.
To place.
Oh!
Oh, Neko Cafe, Neko Cafe, Neko Cafe.
Skateobodo.
Gosh, we're so good at Japanese now.
Sugoi.
Abunai.
Noru.
Whoa, skateobodo.
Sugoi.
Skateobodo.
Abunai.
Noru.
Who's littering here, huh?
Who, who left?
Oh, my gosh.
it's making a little smiley face though.
Coffee no moon.
Coffee Atsui.
Atsui.
Wake up coffee.
Japanese.
Thank you.
But if you drink it, we're just like, ah.
Ah, hotakai coffee.
Oh, hotakai.
Or if it's too hot?
Ah, ita!
Oh, I thought that was a ghost for a second.
Where am I going?
I'm, I'm, I'm raising up.
I'm breaking, I'm gonna break the map.
Oh, oh.
I wish I could go inside stores.
Let's see what else we got.
We got a, um, grocery store here.
Oh, sorry, mini-bini.
Oh!
The Sakura.
Sakura under this beautiful night.
First Mintsupa ever, because I just got a fat work check.
Ironically, we both learned a bit of Japanese at the same
time.
I just took a year-long class and I just finished.
Passed after struggling, but we got a W.
Let's go, Nuto!
Thank you!
Thank you so much and congratulations on passing!
Let's go!
Saku.
What's that one song?
Hana wa Hana wa Hana wa Saku.
Kirei.
Not the Tsuki.
Not the Tsuki is Kirei, but the Hana.
And Hanami!
This is what I wanted to do, Hanami.
The Sakura bloomed right as I was leaving, so I didn't get
to really do Hanami or anything.
the Sakura Matsuri.
Oh no.
This is a t-t- a t-t- it's not a titty it's a city.
I was gonna say it's a town but I also said it was a city so
I then said it was a titty.
Fujiakishi.
I could read the Aki because that's you know.
Haru Natsu Aki Fuyu.
We see what we want to see as well.
I didn't see anything!
I said it.
Oh, what's your name?
Kawakami Nobuo.
Wow.
Oh, Hanabi Tai Kai, fireworks display.
Oh, this one is written.
Tamura Akiko.
She's like, I'm gonna cry.
I'm gonna punch that guy in the face.
Oh no, their cat is missing.
Minto-chan.
Yes, Minto desu.
Welcome to my bishop.
Thank you!
They're looking for their cat.
Neko's a little hat on.
His name is Kitty.
Seibetsu.
I've never seen Os.
And then Nene.
Three months.
No, he's so young.
FBSB, Twitter, Facebook, Chichib, YouTube.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
He has a little hat on.
Oh, he's so young.
Oh, I thought that was a manatee for a second.
Oh, wait.
Should I take a picture of this?
Kei-ji-ban.
I'm surprised it doesn't say like Oshirase or you know
Smashful thanks for the five gifted A lost vanity New Yomu
To read Not Yomu Don't to be mistaken of Yomu from the Toho
project Meido Jozu desune Oh Thank you guys so Something
chome...
I can't read.
Sakura...
Oh, sakurai...
Meiji Chikai.
Sakurai Block 1 Neighborhood Association.
Wow.
The sakurai block.
I guess...
Yeah.
That's where we're at.
Avocado!
Thanks!
Aisukohi.
400 yen.
Not bad.
Today I got to use my yearly exclusive birthday soupa.
Yippee!
Thank you, Goji!
Are you saying that it's your birthday today?
Are you saying it's your birthday?
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Goji!
Two-way you What's today that it's everybody's birthday?
What happened nine months ago?
It's a watering can Mizo yaru to water Sai-mai-siru to grow
Oh boy, heavy Heavy, heavy I think this would be good also
for like Japanese learners wanting to know English, you
know, because it's just like, how do I say this in English?
Oh wait, but they don't say the English pronunciation, so
maybe it's kind of hard.
But you could be like, akarui means bright, or chiker means
turn on, or kesu means turn off, you know?
Labor Day was nine months ago.
All they need is an English voice mode.
Yeah, exactly.
I should make one for English learners as well.
Let's see what we got.
We got Kohi for 400 yen.
We got Furato Waito.
What is a flat white?
What is that?
Me?
No.
400 yen.
Cafe latte for 400 yen.
Coco for 360 yen.
Kyo no soup.
Today's soup is 500 yen.
What's today's soup?
A type of coffee.
Menu!
Tumon suru.
Elabu.
Oh, susume.
Oh, my gosh.
I use that all the time.
Oh, susume wa nandeska.
Oh, look.
This one has the little picture or the camera.
Oh, and this one has the...
Oh.
What was it?
Oh no, I forgot the name.
Something akishi.
Oh no, I forgot!
I'm gonna go read it again.
Ah!
Oh my gosh, we almost just died just then?
Were you here before?
Neko!
Zuru-kashikoi.
That cunning little cat.
Kaout on a pet.
Kawaii!
Kawaii.
Oh, whoops.
Let's see what other borders we've got.
Oh, this one's so cute.
Wait, were you here before?
Why are you giving me that look for?
I like that one too.
Okay, I was.
going to read this.
Fujiaki.
Thanks for the cat, fake me.
Oh wait.
If we do this, is it like a tree?
Sakura.
Oh, this one's also Sakura.
Can you see me?
Or am I a ghost for real?
Am I a ghost for real?
Kagami.
I'm a ghost.
Or a vampire, yeah.
If it weren't raining, this would be pretty aesthetic,
wouldn't it?
Miru.
Walu.
Uh-oh.
Jibun.
Yama?
It's not just any, Yama.
No, Valu.
It's not just any.
Can we get there?
The game hates us.
Oh, I guess...
Okay, run is a toggle.
I've been like trying to...
Oh, we got the ginkgo ATM.
Wow.
looks so beautiful.
What about this?
Is this like a castle?
Oh yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
I wonder what castle this is based off of.
Korai.
Ganko.
Sightseen.
History.
Historical.
Nice.
Oh.
Make 25 photo flashcards.
Let's take a picture of our casa.
Okay.
People are gonna need this.
Kasa!
To get wet.
To hold.
To forget.
Oh my gosh, I forget.
I don't know how many times I've forgotten my umbrella in
Japan.
Mikasa is too Kasa.
Happy basket.
Look at it, a little smiley.
Oh, They're looking for people.
They're hiring.
Oh, that's Spanish.
No, it's not.
I'm pretty sure I just said Japanese.
Let's get this little chow.
No, I'm pretty sure I...
Oh, wait.
I just deleted it.
I'm pretty sure Mikasa...
It's to Casa.
Doko Descalo, Bibliotheca.
Yeah.
Uh, Casa.
Casa.
Like I said, Casa.
Uh, there's not one here.
Hey, slow down, buddy.
Um.
Casa.
I said Casa.
Pretty sure that's, uh, that's, um, Japanese.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, are those the train stations that they say in, in, uh,
In Metal Gear.
Whoa!
You should not just have this out!
Yo, that's...
Oh my god!
Let's go steal somebody's identity.
Taisetsu.
I'm stealing this.
Agawawa.
Agawa.
I must study this further.
Hotel.
Tomaru.
Yasumu.
Takai.
Safety first.
Safety first, everybody.
You see this everywhere with construction.
Anzen Daiichi.
Oh my god!
If you get more than three pieces of steak, you get 10% off!
10% off three or more steaks!
San Mai Ijo.
Cheap mate!
Wait, read the sign.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
I can't read kanji.
Look at this cow.
Why can't I read you?
Oh my god.
I know it's the parts of the cow.
But like...
Tomato.
Show you.
Egg.
My favorite.
Tamago.
I'll show you.
Walu.
To break.
To boil.
Marui.
They are round.
Round little eggies.
320 M for 15.
Xer so expensive now.
Well, recently.
So expensive.
Okay, you guys want to drink?
You guys want to drink?
What is a Genki Cha?
You could have a super sport.
Suika drink!
Suika drink?
No, no, I have the lemon misu, probably.
Misu kudasai.
Nomimono.
Nomu.
Swayaka.
Sosogu.
Yeah, I'm not pouring it to anyone except my mouth.
Pour where?
Inside my mouth.
spaghetti?
Too delicious.
Do you have no spaghetti?
Anzen daisan?
Do they have any niku?
One of the few kanji I actually know.
Niku!
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
I wonder what it will say.
I guess we can't take a picture of that.
Oh, it does say I was gonna say or we can't read it either,
but it does say Stop,
stop.
Oh, let's make an offer and take a picture.
Jinja!
Oh, jiggisiru.
Innoiru.
Oh, yeah, shukyo.
Toro.
Prophet Daichi.
Yeah!
Prophet Daichi!
Akaru.
Takai.
Dekishi.
Yeah, I guess it's like very...
You know, very Japanese.
So I guess you would say historical, right?
It's kind of...
Why is it always raining?
Oh my god.
Tori.
Yeah, but then, yeah, maybe dendoteki would be like more
better to say than historical, right?
KÅrÄi.
Kuguru.
Onion pan.
Congari-to caramel-yro ni.
Yaki-yagi-ta.
Onion bread.
Baked to a golden caramel color.
pan.
Onion pan.
Token pan is super koku.
Oh, no.
Koku-san komugi.
komugi.
I know that one.
100% is used.
All of our bread is made from 100% to domestic wheat,
comugi.
I think this whole game is ilastoya, to be honest.
Look at her!
My nichi, oishi!
Let's take a picture of her.
Panya!
Shumon siru, erabu, yaku.
Mmm.
Look at all this.
Anpan is my favorite.
I love, love, love, anpan.
Which is the red bean.
Red bean.
bun red bean bread benchio
what's your favorite though
tax included actually a lot of a lot of places in Japan do
tax included I feel like most places do or at least they'll
show like the price and then they'll show the price with tax
included so you can at least like You don't have to do the
math on your calculator.
You can at least just have the tax.
And it's so awesome.
Zaycomi.
So great.
It's so much easier.
Also, it's so inexpensive.
Shokopan.
Fluffy milk bread.
Yummy.
Three cheese.
Oh, sanshi cheese.
cheese pan.
France pan.
Meron pan.
Meron pan, meron pan.
Choco corona yummy.
Pita pan.
Oh, it's like a pita bread.
oh, oh, I can't read.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I said it.
Same.
Oh, Peter Pan!
Why would the bread store be selling Peter Pan, you guys?
Why would the bread store, that's kind of messed up.
I like Peter bread, though.
Tough times.
Tough times, nevertheless.
Peter, the horse is here.
Delicious pita bread is loved through the ages.
Why would they write that though?
Oh!
Uh, the, the...
What?
Children eat for free?
Oh my god.
Oh, my god.
Oh, wait, do you need to have a, I mean, I'm a child at
home, so like, Mama Maria.
Everybody go to Mama Maria, apparently.
Okosama Ranchi.
Yes, Okosama Ranchi.
But sometimes they have Otona no Okosama Ranchi.
Or if you want, so it's like the child's, the children's
menu, right?
But sometimes they have a children's menu made for adults.
So that if you're just like...
I...
Go me.
I took a picture of you!
Um, so that, uh, if you want the stuff on the children's
menu, you can have it.
Stere.
BUNBETS SURU!
Kusai.
This is the most annoying thing.
BUNBET SURU.
Separate?
Okay.
most annoying things to like throw away in japan was my
makeup because okay imagine you get a oh my god eating mike
tarsha's ass thanks for the five captain thank you so much
make it that cute um uh imagine you get a a waterproof like
you know something like a waterproof concealer right and In
Japan, you have to, like, rinse out all your stuff.
And, like, it was so annoying because it's waterproof.
So I'm, like, trying to get the water inside the little tube
and then trying to get it to come out.
And it was just so, oh, it was so annoying.
It was so awful.
Oh, my gosh.
Our picture together.
Well, not together.
Okay.
Oh,
look at this.
What is this?
Fun, goo-me.
Oh, kashi.
Oh,
my.
Oh, ishi.
Wakheru.
Uh, no, I'm not dividing anything.
I'm not dividing.
I'm eating this whole bag myself.
Oh, good morning.
Good morning, world.
Oh, we're back here!
Wait, what's this?
Egao Dori?
What's on the Egao Street over here?
Hold on.
We're going down there.
We're gonna go see.
Oh,
wait.
We can get Deko-chan!
Pigua!
Achimmeru!
Otaku!
Shumi.
What does she know, Shumiwa?
Idolu.
Wait, what is this thing?
What is this thing?
Well, yeah, but what kind of nui-gurumi?
Flap, flap.
Takishimmeru.
Ageru.
What is that?
It's a whale?
Perhaps?
Oh, umi no hime.
Look at her.
My wife.
What if I took a picture of something and it said wife?
It's a business hour.
That's also probably important.
Kanji to know.
Eiji-o-jikan.
Fiorara good.
Thanks for the...
Wait, how many did you gift what thank you for the tank
after thank you thank you thank you
this isn't just in my head this isn't just this is real this
is not It's just my Chunibyo delusions.
This is real!
I like it.
Cute!
Decorah!
Erindolf fan exchange meeting.
Koryukay.
Erindolfan Koryukaya.
Wow.
She must be so popular.
Popular idol.
I love that there's a clip art for Chunigirl.
They have so many awesome...
Awesome.
Koi no yo-kan.
Prominition of love.
Um, they have so many different illustrations, you would be
surprised.
Taisen!
Like, you got the fighting game floor, you got the...
Auto- I'm sorry.
Auto-ge- Auto-ge floor.
The on-ge-ge game.
Auto-ge.
Race game.
Prize game.
Crane game.
Let's sound this way.
Look how cute.
Does someone just leave their purse and their food?
I'll take that.
Tabemono.
Yummy, yummy.
Taberu.
Oh, you see.
Carai!
Game, game.
What's this one?
Look at how, like, fancy you can make these.
Look at this.
Look at the bouquet and everything.
Nomimono.
Charlie.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Can we go?
Can we...
Banana!
Oh, the backo!
Yes, stand-bol.
I know that because of...
um because of uh uh the girl with the yotsuba
just a box
submit it just a box just a box
Can I go upstairs?
No!
Why would you deny me?
What's the point?
Oh.
Egaodori.
Smile Street.
Man.
I was so excited.
Take a picture of the door to darkness?
No?
Okay.
Wow, I guess it's a pretty small map, isn't it?
Otaku-ma.
Ah!
Get it because it's Otaku and Kuma.
Kuma is bear and then Otaku- Otaku-Kuma?
Does someone mention the door to darkness?
That's the bear.
Hey, a maid cafe?
Yes!
It's based off of Made Dreamin.
Actually, the sign is pretty close and the logo.
Made Dreamin, Made Melody, You made the country, let's go.
Oh.
Mao, no, no, no, no, no.
Demon King's life.
Access denied, though.
They banned me.
I've been banned from the Made Cafe.
I've been banned
Wait, guitar girls
Wait, two-year-old Wait, two-year-old Hatsubai-chu
Hatsubai-chu It's another one you hear all the time On sale
now Have you guys ever heard of guitar girls?
It's probably like Lifetime ban No No, no, they wouldn't
ever.
I mean, they kicked me out by my butt and said, if we ever
see you again here, we're calling the cops.
But I don't think that I mean that for a lifetime.
I don't think they mean that for that long.
Probably until like next week, you know?
They kicked me to the curb right on my poor, poor bottom.
And they said, you better not step another foot inside this
establishment or we're calling the cops.
But I don't think they meant that for life.
If they meant it for life, they should have said, In our
whole life!
But also, I'm dead.
So, um, that's kind of discriminatory to me.
I don't, my afterlife never ends.
They're just being soon?
Yeah, I hope so.
Fusen!
Fukuramas.
Walu.
Pan.
Oh, no.
Why is it making the space?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, can we go down here?
Fujiaki Den-Tets.
Fujiaki Electric Railway.
Sakurai Eki.
Oh, my gosh.
I want to go see a Shizen-N-Modoru.
Is he gonna...
Wait a second.
Why is the chef...
Why is the chef around all these edible animals?
Also, what a movie to release.
Okay, is this a romance?
It's being released on Valentine's Day.
Wait.
What is he intending to do with them?
Return to nature, like return them to nature, or...
Whoa!
Get it!
Looks like that plane had some panties on.
Wait.
Where did it go?
Huh?
Ghost plane?
Where did it go?
Oh!
There's another cat!
Neko!
This is such a beautiful Keshiki Oh wow I actually got
something Gaito Gaito High, high Hossoi I want Okay I want a
picture Of him With the leaf like falling in the background
really artsy you know how is pa's today oh my god she is
such a troublemaker she is such a little troublemaker she is
so so wait no i wanted it behind it hold on let's try
another one oh no i was too late um she okay so i have a
From my time in Japan, when I went to high school, I have a
thousand paper cranes that my classmates created for me.
And I've kept it all this time.
And guess what has holes in it now?
Because she can't stop biting it.
She's like, all the time.
And then there's also a box that I have filled with letters
that were sent to me.
And she keeps trying to knock it over.
There's too many letters that I don't know what to do.
do with them yet i might have to get like a really really
really big scrapbook or something but i don't know what to
do with it yet and she keeps trying to knock over the box
she's such a menace and so she'll go from the box to the
cranes back to the box to the cranes and then she'll try and
chew on every cord that i have which you know by my computer
i have quite a few so she's just such
Why did your classmates make a thousand cranes for you?
Oh, because I was leaving.
I was going home, and so they were like, Minto time, we had
so much fun with you here.
We'll miss you so much.
Yeah, I was leaving.
So sad.
Yeah.
Not because you died.
Why would they make that for me because I died?
Where are the leaves?
Oh.
It looks like it's on his head!
Frui.
Rekishi.
History.
Historical history.
When you...
Basically, the thousand cranes is like you make a wish.
So...
Murphy, thanks.
Crazy.
It's like people like you or something.
That'd be it.
Why?
Huh?
No.
Why?
What is the top one so we can tell Matara?
Furui.
I think, I feel like Nekishiteki would be like a sick
insult, you know?
Instead of like, instead of calling someone just old, you
call them historical.
You're just like, damn girl, you're not just old.
Like you are historical.
Like, whoa, Nekishiteki.
It's like ancient, but like...
It's like a sophisticated insult.
Knowing her though, she'd take it as a compliment.
Can I take a picture of the rock?
Iwa?
Iwa!
Wait, what's the difference between Iwa and Ishii?
Are Ishii smaller?
Ooki!
Omori!
Katai!
this oh this is a akihabara
wait wait wait wait i gotta tell tell it say a joke um i
gotta say a joke uh your mom
Boo!
I knew you'd like it, I knew you'd like it.
I knew you guys would like it.
What about this thing?
It's just here.
I should be able to take a picture of everything.
Oh, the cat.
No, this is a different cat.
Oh.
Litter, litter, litter.
Oh, just...
Nomimono.
Why don't you call it Mizu?
You're right, your mom is...
See?
It's a pretty sophisticated joke, is it not?
It's a pretty...
It's a pretty, pretty sophisticated joke, is it not?
Oh, hats, coats, accessories...
Apparel?
Accessory?
Coato?
I love this.
borrowed word except Boshi.
Which...
Is that?
Is that a Chinese, like, taken word, I wonder?
If anybody knows.
But it's so funny, everything else is a borrowed word.
Boshi the Rock.
Wait, why can't I read it?
No, why can't I read it?
it i can't read double low double single no no no no no no
no no tp toilet paper toilet paper wondering taco thank you
for the video thank you thank you so much thank you
so one thing that i like had to learn um or rather you i
guess you learn kind of quickly is um is when you say so you
say like you know when you're at this when you're at a
restaurant you you get something on your mouth or whatever
you use a napkin but in japanese napkin has a totally
different meaning napkin napkin don't go to a restaurant
well You could.
You could go to a restaurant and ask for an apokin.
But, um...
But, uh...
You might, um...
What does it mean, though?
It means...
Um...
It means a sanitary pad.
The things that, um...
You know, when you're on your...
period so if you go to a restaurant and say hey can i get a
pad with my meal people might be like um oh we have a
freaking unless you're at wait
did did that did that podcast episode go up about um the
jail.
I think it did though, right?
Oh wait, no, it wasn't the podcast.
It was, uh, with Giddy.
The collab with Giddy.
Where, um, I went to a prison-themed restaurant.
And, um, in what restaurant would that possibly be normal?
Exactly what I'm saying!
There was, there was, there was a jail-themed restaurant,
and they would serve like, um, they would serve like a
strawberry jam type stuff on a on a on a on a sanitary
napkin it wasn't menstruation themed cafe they just had i
think it was just that one thing that was which i would hope
there's nothing more yawarakae suaru marui
but this by itself is kusuri
And this, the, the, the, this one, the, oh, the Kyoku, the
Kyoku part, the Kyoku part is, um, kind of means like a type
of, how do you say, like a building, not a bit, like a, how
would you say?
If the Okiakusama asks for a napkin, the Okiakusama shall
have a napkin.
That's the Japanese service I expect.
Oh, can we go, no!
now oh this is an important kanji right here this this is an
important kanji tabe taberu is to eat right tabe holdai
sometimes you will say no me in front of this no me holdai
tabe holdai all you can eat baby all you can eat 3,200 yen
wow that's not so bad for all you can eat.
All you can eat, baby.
Yeah, and then nomi hodai, all you can drink.
Nomi hodai, tabe hodai.
Taisetsetsu na nihonu desu.
Taisetsu na nihonu da teoimasu!
How much is that in America?
Nowadays, maybe like twenty-five dollars.
Maybe like a $25 Oh sushi Hayashi sushi Hayashi sushi Yamae
More like 20?
Wait Is it that bad?
More like 20 bucks a current?
See I thought I was being generous with 25 Oh my gosh Oh I
should I should order some yen I've been trying to like
order yen um i typically have been using my card as much as
i can while in japan but like eventually it's gonna go back
up right so i've been ordering it and this just kind of
holding on to like the the yen bills so that like whenever
it goes back up i won't have to spend more money
stonks Stonks.
Stonks, stonks, stonks.
Will it go back?
I sure, I don't know.
Boss, do you have any kazoo cover requests?
Me?
Can I request one?
For real?
Um...
Have you done Snake Eater?
I think that would be a good one.
Yeah.
Snake Eater.
yen and cat are around the same so i guess that's 30 bucks
no i don't i think that's even i think that's too much hold
on i'm gonna look it up yen wait oh oh wait is this from
today oh my gosh i have an amy amy payment request oh okay
it's not so expensive that's for a free rent thing that i
god okay um oh i just noticed it though oh my gosh okay usd
to yen okay yen uh three thousand two hundred it's twenty
dollars oh my god you guys were right pyrobug thanks you for
the 10 thank you for the 10 memberships thank you also shabu
shabu ah shabu
I love shabu shabu.
Hmm.
Have I gotten a picture of a car yet?
Caruma!
Unten suru!
Hayao!
Oh, sooo!
Can I go down here?
Oh wait, there's another...
Entrance for Sakurai Station.
Sakurai Eki.
But what line is it?
Shabu Shabu is the best Oh no People are leaving their stuff
everywhere Caban Caban what is that I don't know why it's in
I've always wondered why it's in Katakana Is it a borrowed
word?
If so what Where is it borrowed from?
Ideru Dasu Hokobu Oh sorry Hakobu Oh my gosh Hakobu
Kabanchan There is a Kanji phone.
Cabang.
Why in Katakana though?
And then they're leaving their suitcase here.
Can I take a picture of the graffiti?
Oh my god, I can!
Raccoon City.
Nakagaki!
The first one!
Iho!
Legal.
Car- Car-ful!
Oh my god.
Not the...
Illegal.
Oh wait, here.
Shashingo.
You're doing illegal activities.
What have we missed?
Raku-gaki.
You're doing illegal activities.
Hmm, what have we missed?
I think uh...
There was a area to the left down here that we didn't go to.
And of course Fujisan.
Yeah, over here.
Oh, there's a bathroom.
Excuse me.
Pedestrian walking.
I wonder if they'll...
My favorite!
My favorite, my favorite!
My favorite flowers!
Hana?
Hana!
And these are Ajisai!
They're my favorite!
Hydrangea love!
I love Ajisai.
Kirei.
Mizuoyaru.
Saku.
Hydrangea.
Can I crouch in this game?
Oh, nice.
So I can get like a really aesthetic nice photo of the
Hydrangea.
Wait, no, no.
There we go.
That's better.
Ah!
What are you doing here?
Neko.
What are you doing there, little cat?
Whoa!
This is how my cat looks at me.
Toilets.
Can I not take a picture of the toilets?
Oh.
Kenyan!
Smoking is prohibited.
No smoking.
This says toilets.
In case you couldn't figure it out.
Wait.
Why is it like this?
What is this?
Oh, okay.
So this is for, like, the, you know, the bigger ones and the
ones for, like, families and stuff this is the ladies room
but why is there also a man sign right there
hmm why do the doors have windows i don't think they're i
think this is only one the one that's one person but it's
you can't see inside because it has the lock thing down here
but and it's occupied i gotta pee Please let me in.
Anybody!
Let me in!
Please!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm not gonna make it!
I'm not gonna make it!
There's so many...
There's so many magazines.
Oh, there's our guitar girls.
What is this one?
Oh!
Before you go, before you go, kiss me.
Gojo-kun.
Where?
What is it?
Where is it which you talk to me?
Satoru.
Thank me for the wish that I was gone.
Wait, no, he said his name two times in a row.
Wait.
Manga.
Oh, my favorite.
They're both names, Satoru!
They are?
Really?
Oh.
Can I read the titles?
Girl's band.
Manga.
Paper bound.
Paper boundo.
Hanya.
Where's the gravier magazines?
Is it you?
No, this is a fashion magazine.
I don't care.
Where's the gravier?
Where's the baboom and the babang?
Where is it?
One, one, jump.
Oh, it's like a game.
Woof, woof, jump.
Sumaho, they download.
They keep the steamy stuff inside.
I once stayed at a hotel that was across the street from
a...
I guess a publishing company, but they published like a ton
of like, um, uh, the, it was like, not Shonen Jump, but one
of the magazines that has like the steamier, the steamier,
the more, the more, oh, la la, uh, mangas and stuff like
that.
And so they just had them out on display.
I wonder if I have a picture.
Hold on, I'm gonna look.
Because I was so like, it was so funny to see it every time
I would, um, let's see, when did I go, when did I stay?
Maybe this trip.
Hmm.
Oh, no, wait.
Maybe it was this trip.
No.
I'm looking at my phone right now if you couldn't tell.
Seinen manga?
I guess maybe technically, but it was like, so sexy.
It was so sexy.
And like, they're also, like, you know how, um, like,
they'll have the the grab your models on the front and
everything.
And I would, like, go and get food, and then every time I
would pass this, this, like, sign of sexy girls.
It was kind of awesome.
Hmm.
No.
Oh, wait.
Was it this one?
No.
Oh, when did I say?
When did I stay there?
I can't remember at all.
Hmm.
Staying at too many hotels all the time.
Is this?
This is...
Is it this one?
Is it this?
no if i can find it later i'll show you guys it was a really
nice hotel though it was a very nice hotel and it wasn't
very expensive and it was a good location so um i'd
recommend it to you guys if i could never remember i never
could i remember when i stayed there i have no idea
my memory is going wait is it this one it's gonna bother me
now I'm so sorry no I'm just like looking for it it's really
gonna bother me if I don't if I don't look at least a little
bit if I don't wait I'm under camera right yeah yeah under
camera it was definitely with this camera but it wasn't here
not there not that
who knows You can find it, Mint.
I can't.
Oh, I can't find it.
I want to play Guitar Star.
I feel like this is such a good game, actually, to like,
learn so much.
We got our menu.
What's your favorite kind of ramen?
I think for me, my favorite is Shoyu Ramen.
Which is, uh...
Like the soy sauce.
Tonkatsu.
Wow, lots of people saying Tonkatsu.
Really?
Classic Tonkatsu.
Tonkatsu.
Wow, so many people push Tonkatsu.
Wow.
Karage.
Miso.
what you so hum you so what i think i've only ever had mr
noodle what's a mr noodle
boo boo you guys love it thank you thank you you guys are
too kind you guys are too kind black garlic tonkots okay i
like anything with garlic in it too oh my gosh when they're
just like I'm like, give me that garlic.
Put as much garlic as you want.
Mojashi is what?
Mojashi is, um, whoo.
Mojashi is, um, the beans.
Not the beans.
Um, I keep wanting to say string bean, but it's not that.
It's a, like, bean sprouts, thank you.
Bean sprouts.
I don't like a mojashi.
I always get no mojashi.
I don't like mojashi.
I don't like it.
Yeah, it's not my favorite.
But they add crunch.
I don't like it, though.
I don't like bean sprouts.
Yeah!
See?
Every good person, every base person doesn't like bean
sprouts.
Cletus, welcome to Memboshi!
I also, like, Japan.
Japan loves cabbage and I don't mind cooked cabbage but like
raw cabbage is so it's they'll just have a pile of raw
cabbage and I'm like it's so the taste is so strong it's so
bitter not a big fan not a big fan mmm cabbage I like it
though if it's if it's uh Cooked cabbage is awesome.
I prefer raw to cook cabbage.
Why?
Can we read this?
No.
There it is.
Your tonkots ramen.
There you guys go.
Pork broth ramen.
700 yen for 700 yen.
You will be full.
Full stomach for 700 yen.
Yep.
Tonkots ramen.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Curry.
Wait, I cannot even...
Who puts white text on top of yellow?
I can't even read it.
I can't even...
What is a curry retort?
Rettort curry.
Oh, I can't read it.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so hard to read.
I can't even read it.
Oh, no, pets.
Pet-pick-pins.
Oh, my gosh.
Kine-n-kine-kine.
Oh, sorry.
Satsuhi-kinesi.
So you can't wear your helmet inside.
It's kind of weird request, right?
Whoa!
Oh, chusen is like evil word, right?
It's lottery.
Chusen de Hachiman Mesa.
Do a lot of people still smoke in Japan?
Yeah, they do.
I think so.
They do.
What's the difference between Kenyan and Kienchi?
Kenyan is specifically for smoking.
And Kienchi is just like for like not allowing you to do
something else.
So it can be like, Tatsiri Kienchi, do not enter.
Daily reminder, no.
I love you, man.
Inumei, thank you!
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, no problem.
Mm-hmm.
So that, for that petokinshi, is no pets.
Tobacco.
Oh, sake.
Odin!
Ginko ATM.
What does this say?
Buham camera.
Sadochu.
Oh,
can I take a picture of this?
No.
They don't want to take me to take a picture of the sign.
What else have I gotten?
Where's the moiru?
Oh, moirusel.
No, I like it when I say moiru because it's kind of like
moe.
Sometimes, like, I've seen places.
I suppose I think it's specifically like I've seen them in
Akiba, but like they'll kind of make a joke about like Moe,
you know Moe being like But also Moe means like burnt to
burn, right?
Moe-er-gomi is like burnable garbage.
So Moeer, Moeer Moeer gomi Moeer gomi
I don't know.
Mourer!
Oh,
you put your beans and your cans and your petal bottles.
Oh my gosh, it's your bowl, you guys!
Food bowl!
Ippie!
Aku!
Kitanai!
Okay, eat up, eat up!
Eat up, eat up, eat up!
There's no food.
Sad.
We'll do it in black and white because it's depressing that
there's none.
Oh, Kaido no Aki no.
It's like, okay, so flavor and then remember.
So it's like, so was it saying like, remember the flavor of
Hokkaido fall?
I love a kabocha so much.
Oh, autumn taste, wait.
Mikaku.
Hokkaido no akito mikaku.
Kabocha koroche.
In the mail, because it's a five-year-old.
Thank you.
Mikaku, Mikaku.
But she would feed us nothing but raw cabbage.
What?
No, I care about you guys more than that.
Or if we go someplace, I would give you my raw cabbage that
I don't want to eat.
Alright, so welcome to a membership.
Thank you!
I love a kabocha, a pumpkin.
So good.
Oh, kabocha koroke.
I love koroke too.
Did we go over here?
Udon.
Teuchi Udon.
Shinosuke.
Handmade in noodles.
Whoa.
Wait, are these like the samples?
Are they gonna say...
Oh, they do say tabemono.
But this isn't a tabemono.
So actually, one thing that's really fun, I don't know if
you, I did it through school.
So I don't know how easy it would be for foreigners to book
an appointment.
But you know how like in Japanese restaurants, they'll have
the sample foods that like exactly like this there.
They sit outside and show you what kind of stuff that they,
the ultra realistic plastic models.
Exactly, exactly.
I went to, I went to a factory.
I don't know if you call it a factory, but I went to the
place that makes them.
do have a gift store in the front too that you can um i
think anybody can go to open to the public and buy um some
kits that you can make your own um but also i think it's i
think it would be really fun if you ever go to japan and
you're wanting something to do that's kind of unique they do
have like workshops where you can create your own and then
they show you the process i think we made like tempura and
then you get to take it home too so uh it's really cool it's
really fun and they have they i wonder let me see if i can
find it let's see sample japan food sample workshop i don't
even know what to search food sample making workshop in oh
my gosh wait it just took it was so easy to search i don't
know if this is the exact place that i did it at but
Is that some place in Ikebukuro?
I don't remember where I went to.
Maybe this is it.
Hmm.
But yeah, I guess you can book it.
And then they also have the gift shop.
So if you're just like, oh, we made this thing, but I want
to make this at home.
Like I bought a melon soda one.
So yeah.
I recommend that kind of experience.
It's so fun.
It's my Osusume.
Remember we said Osusume?
What is this?
There's no menu there.
So, icicle here.
These places always have this specific ice cream cone.
Gosh.
Just leaving their sumaho outside.
How do I get coins?
No sticker.
Soft cream.
What do you think?
Haru.
Hagasu.
T-Sai.
Try a different mode.
Tab.
Oh, these are all our pictures.
Cute.
Ah!
Oh, wow.
Here's all your hiragana and katakana.
Hiragana, dakten.
Katakana, dakten.
Wow.
Numbers!
Oh!
Wow.
Oh, my gosh!
There's even greetings in here.
stuff?
Oh, hi-gozaiimasu.
Oh,
it's a man.
What's the next page?
Expressions.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
GOMENNASO GOMENNASO OTSKARESAMA OTSKARESAMA Yeah This is
pretty detailed It even has like look at this Wow They're
telling you all about it Like Sunday has the kanji for sun
slash day Saturday is the kanji for earth Friday is the
kanji for gold money baby Getziobe Wait what's this?
Oh it doesn't okay it doesn't tell you the the meaning.
Days two.
KyÅ, ashta, asate, kino, ototoi.
Heyjitsu.
Shumatsu.
That's important.
Because shumatsu is awesome, baby.
Complicated kanji.
How many pages are there?
Watashi.
Anata.
Oh, my.
Very informal way of saying you.
And sounds very rude.
You!
Oh,
and it teaches you like the difference between This, That,
That, That, That, that.
You?
Wasabi.
This is great for people, beginners, right?
Sounds pretty ganky to me.
Play it up a little bit more, Samu.
Hana-chan-where-doko-doko-doko?
Koko-doko-doko?
I just heard a dog bark.
Did I imagine that?
Did a dog?
Mitsu!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, it's in like the Oh my gosh, it's in like the
Oh, he's even got money Whoa, he's got a lot of money Oh,
he's got a lot of money Oh,
honey No!
Oh wow.
They can't do change, so you pay the...
Oh, it says right.
Pay the exact amount.
You got their gummies?
It's a pun on tobacco.
It's even like the same...
same kind of font that they use in Japan all the time.
Thanks for the coin!
Oh, I got no.
Marvery, thanks for the coin.
Doggo can't do math.
No, Doggo need... Wait, who?
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Who spent...
$1,500?
How much would that be now?
$130?
Uh, $110?
Well, who spent over $100 on snacks?
I would too though.
He's a good boy.
He's such a good boy.
Beats is a good boy.
They do.
Sorry.
What was I doing though?
I was doing something and then I got distracted.
Was I still looking at the samples?
No, I closed out of that.
I don't remember what I was doing.
Sani was atashi, so I wasn't the dog girl.
Oh, you're probably right.
Oh, someone's...
Oh, yes, that's right.
We were going through here.
I was like...
Thank you.
Yuki-chan is to become a VTuber.
She's so cute.
Oh, we have some vocabulary.
Game will she must.
Oh, I don't want to be my son.
Oh.
Wow.
Making sentences.
Introduction.
Oh.
Yuki-chan, this is Samu.
Samu-yo.
Oh, she's so cute!
Wait, I think I need to turn the...
Oh, my God.
Sorry, the voices are so low.
Let's turn it up just a little bit.
There we go.
Wait, is that a voice changer?
I'm Yuki.
I'm 5 years old.
Which is so cute!
I'm so cute!
I'm Yuki.
Oh, Yuki.
Yuki.
Hey, it's great.
The photographer is cool, right?
I'm Mito, I'm 5 years.
I'm 5 years.
Hey, it's great.
What is that?
Why?
Why is it so scary?
Why the Yuki-chan is cute, but the Mito is cute!
Eh, it's great!
The photo is cool, right?
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
I'm stealing her identity.
I'm stealing her.
I'm minto.
I'm 5 years.
Yuki, this is
Samu.
Hi.
Hi, my name is Sam.
I'm a photographer.
Thank you.
Oh, wow!
The photographer is cool, right?
I'm Yuki.
I'm 5 years.
I'm a robot robot.
I'm a long-ago-ago-ago 5 years.
I'm 5 years.
I'm Yuki this.
Mint isn't just a child at heart anymore.
Okay, okay, I'm done.
I'm done.
Oh, no, there's more!
Oh, my gosh.
I don't think he was saying that about the curry.
That sounded more like, Yes, I like that sounded like a
confession to me, right?
I think he likes Haina.
I love it.
Then, itadakimasu.
Itadakimasu.
It's delicious.
It's good.
Thank you so much.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be listening to this just like when I
feel a little bit lonely.
Samu-san, do you- what do you think about me?
Yes, I like it.
Oh my god, Samu-san, it's too early we just met today!
Samu-san, konichiwa, konichiwa, koniichiwa, He's asking her
on a date.
Wow, there's so...
We're on page 24.
Let's buy a book!
Ooh.
Are you gonna buy this book?
Un kao!
Oh, oh!
Rival!
Wait, oh no, that's the Tain-san.
That's the Tain-san.
Hi.
We can't see the rival.
There he is.
There he is, there he is.
What, is my head too big or something?
Oh, oh, oh my gosh, this is so, oh my gosh, this is actually
so helpful.
Wow, oh, and then it stops there.
Hmm, but that's a lot.
That's a lot of stuff that they, that they include in this.
I'm actually so impressed.
Wow, beautiful.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Capture a butterfly.
Oh, there's an achievement for it.
Wait, what's this?
Tegami.
Caku.
Okuru.
Gotta answer the point card question with Dajjobu desu, so
you skip the next question.
Wait, if they say, do you have a point card, you can't say
Dajjobu desu.
Just say, oh, what the, are you saying like, oh, they're
gonna ask you if you wanna make one, right?
Dajjobu desu.
Why are you spying on other people's mail?
Because I'm a snoop.
I gotta get all these pictures.
I have all these pictures to take.
Though I answer Daijoba this to probably 99% of stuff.
Oh my god.
Square watermelons.
Suica.
Cudamono.
Deku suku suru.
Dekai.
Look how expensive.
How expensive it is though!
Oh my gosh.
It's so dang expensive.
You guys, I ate a whole bag of carrots recently.
I ate all of them in one day.
I love carrots.
Yes, I eat.
I ate them all because they're They're healthy.
Can you see in the dark now?
Just carrots?
Um, most...
Some with hummus.
But mostly just by themselves.
Saibai suru.
Oh, yeah, the daikon.
Daikon.
That's a nice radish.
I love a mikan too.
Mikan.
I can also eat a whole bag of these in Wonderland.
But then my stomach hurts.
So I don't do it.
Not often.
Only sometimes.
What about the chocolate chips?
Oh, I'll get this one too.
Are you looking for a part-time job?
A whole bag?
Yeah, I can...
a whole bag.
Bowshow too days.
Mabashi brand.
Horse.
Oh, what's this one?
Something, something, chewy.
Go.
Goho.
Chewie?
I don't know.
Goho.
Goho, chewy.
Oh, my God.
Mint is Japanese.
But is she ego-jouzu?
I'm nothing-jouzu.
Nothing Jozu at all.
Nothing Jozu about it.
Wait, actually, can I get a picture of the Ajisai in the
rain?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, no!
Why did I have to turn dark?
Wait, oh, I want a picture of the train, too.
I guess we'll wait for it to come back.
Sorry, everybody.
I gotta get my shot.
I want the moon in it also.
Pachinko!
Sora!
No!
No no no no no no no no no no!
No no no no no no no!
Delete delete.
Oh!
It doesn't pause!
Dencha.
What a terrible photo.
What the?
Oh!
Yeah, we got the pachinko in the background.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Was that lighting?
I don't know what that was, to be honest.
N 'olu.
Oril.
Hayaai.
Pachinko.
Oh.
Dang.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi-hi
Toei, tobu, yoko, ni-i-kou.
Mm-hmm.
Remember the rule of thirds.
Didn't it highlight the sky let you know?
Oh, I've already taken a picture of the sky, though, see?
You can see it kind of- it's hard to tell.
I can't show my mouse on it, but it says Sora.
It says so...
Uh-oh.
We're causing a...
We're causing a pile up here.
Sorry, everybody.
Go ahead.
I'm not sorry.
Right?
We're not sorry at all.
We're ready to cause chaos in this little town.
Can we go downstairs?
No.
Oh, yes.
This is where the...
the their meal is free for the kids.
Okosama menu.
Do you guys feel really Nihonko Jozu now?
Do you guys feel like you've learned so much?
I think I might actually call it here.
I know it's like super duper, super duper short stream.
But my throat is hurting quite a bit.
So sure do.
Wait, hold on.
Let's get the perfect photo of Fuji-san first.
Excuse me!
You are hindering my photo.
Let it be a little bit lighter.
See, it's kind of twilight.
Fuji-san.
Japanese go slightly more jiu-jitsu.
Fujisan.
Nihonko peko peko desu.
Hanzen daichi...
Hanzen daisan!
Hello?
Is it gonna...
become daytime?
Yama?
Yama.
Oh yeah, see before it was raining.
Fuji Yama!
Dekai Yama!
I'm sorry!
What is the second?
The second is...
The second is Moe.
It's so big, Fuji-san.
Yama!
Yeah, baby!
We got the ultimate photo.
Yama?
No, let me see it.
I'm going to heart the yama.
Wow.
It's so beautiful.
Thank you.
This was a comfy street.
game honestly looks more useful than the green owl app for
learning nihon go have a good rest thank you akafuji look at
that little cat so cute yeah i'm actually so shocked at how
how like i feel like how effective this is oh my gosh do you
see it even the kanji is in the look how cool that is wow
what a beautiful picture Oh, I missed the shot.
I missed the shot.
I want another car to...
Wait, what am I highlighting?
Super.
I'd love to see this game grow.
Me too!
Me too, honestly.
I think it'd be great for like, especially kind of the kanji
you see in everyday Japan.
I think.
Super duper helpful Come
on car Go turn turn turn Turn down the street car Someone
turn down the street Go home Did someone say super Super no
Wrong super Wrong one Oh Oh my god Kuduma There like
Japanese
they need an N2 version of the game yeah yeah it's a yeah
just like having
everything I don't know even what N2 would be like though it
would be so intensive right it would it would be like every
individual thing right but it looks like almost that they
want to add more maps you know because I mean they have
these area oh wait can you get the fish Oh Oh Oh
It's kind of a bad picture but that's okay pretty much hence
the invisible wall mmm
I think so too.
I think it's really, really good.
Yeah.
Oh my god, wait!
So cute!
Wait, is this the cat from over here?
No!
There's just cats everywhere.
No focus on the cat.
Wait, I don't, I wish I could lift it up a little bit more.
But it goes out of, there we go.
Oh no, I clicked the wrong thing.
Okay, once more Sakura fell, fall and then we'll be.
Nyanko.
Nyan-chan.
What's the cat doing?
He is, he's, um, he's...
I'm contemplating as life choices.
Don't do it, Cat.
Don't do it, Cat!
Oh, uh...
I pressed left click, but it didn't work.
Yeah, he's Hanami right now.
Hanami.
No!
Wait.
Oh, it's not letting me take a picture because I'm not
focused on something.
Wait.
Kawa?
That's a terrible picture of...
Kawa.
That's a terrible picture.
Kawa?
Kawa.
Can I get this one too?
Is this a bridge actually?
I can't tell.
I guess not.
I was hoping it would let me take a picture of the bridge,
but...
Okay.
Yeah, I'm really sorry for the super duper short stream
today.
really wanted something kind of chill that we could uh
explore around a little bit and learn some nihongo and um
hang out for just a bit and um hopefully you learned
something hopefully thanks for the chill stream of course of
course um i if you're wanting to learn japanese i actually
recommend this so much because it look at this you can go to
a sign and you can be like what this looks like something
that you would see like totally normally and so if you're
just like oh oh like oh what does this mean you know it's a
super duper helpful hmm it was fun and educational yes
educational yes yes I want to play game so bad and i'm n3
yeah do it anyway i think um i mean there are even some
words that i was like oh and then for me kanji is so bad
that it's it helps me a lot yeah i learned today that mint
is kawaii that word wasn't in the game thanks for the chill
stream of course of course of course I'm not the sense I'm
not the sensei don't worry this game is sensei wow the suck
things are the five gift and membership thank you oh we
almost died we almost died we almost died again whoa I want
to watch that spanking Thanks for the 10!
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you so much.
April 26, baby.
I do hope that they...
There is like DLC for this game, but it's only for filters.
So hopefully they add more maps and I don't think I'll
stream it again, obviously.
Because, you know, it's just...
It seems more like a good way to study on your own and have
an interactive way to study if you're more of that kind of
person who, like, better by like look being like oh kutsu
like that you know then it could be really good thank you
guys thank you thank you thank you with more advanced
japanese words on certain maps i think it would be good you
still have to eat that by the way oh look at the time okay
everybody ozumi Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you very much.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye